l'opt l'observatoire des sciences de
l'univers de l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines à l'honneur ce
soir dans la chronique environnement oui
absolument il s'agit de parler de couche
d'ozone et de réchauffement climatique
est avec nous ce soir
sophie gaudin big man djédjé oubliée
hautes-noues pardon un grand soir ses
dettes avec nous et vous êtes la
nouvelle directrice en fête de l'eau vs
qu l'observatoire de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines depuis le 1er
juillet dernier
pourquoi avoir accepté ce poste qu'est
ce qui vous a motivée en fait qui m'a
motivé c'est de pouvoir m'investir un
peu dans le management de la recherche
après des années de recherches
personnelles pour parce que le les
observatoire des sciences de l'univers
sont des structures assez spécifique
dans l'université ce sont des structures
à la fois
favorisant l'enseignement pour
l'université mais aussi qui ont pour
mission l'observation et la recherche
donc c'est des structures assez
particulière et qui ont des missions
intéressantes mais concret votre
parcours alors je suis spécialiste de la
couche d'ozone
c'est le sujet que j'ai poursuivi au
cours de ma carrière de recherche
voilà d'accord et donc qu'elle sous les
missions de l'eau vs qu aujourd'hui
alors les missions sont
l'observation
l'enseignement et la recherche
est votre rôle en qualité de directrice
de nouvelles directrices aujourd'hui
masse et d'animer un peu tout ça c'est à
dire de favoriser l'enseignement au sein
de l'ové est-ce qu qui est une
composante de l'ue vs qu l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin de favoriser
les observations dans le domaine du
climat de la pollution atmosphérique
mais aussi
l'utilisation des données issues des
instruments spatiaux pour l'étude de la
planétologie et favoriser aussi des
recherches interdisciplinaires
puisque en fait lober est-ce qu abrite
certain nombre de laboratoires
qui sont issus de communautés
différentes à la fois
les communautés des sciences physiques
mais aussi des sciences humaines et
sociales et donc le but c'est un peu de
faire dialoguer ses différentes
communautés sur des sujets communs
intéressant le climat ou la pollution ou
l'environnement général
paul tout neuf là c'est véritablement
des conditions idéales pour travailler
oui tout à fait c'est ça a été ouvert en
fait en 2010 donc c'est vrai qu'on a des
nouveaux locaux c'est on a beaucoup de
choses à installer notamment il ya une
plateforme intégration et test qui
permet qui a pour objectif de permettre
le test d'instruments spatiaux qui sont
développés dans les laboratoires et donc
on est en train d'installer cette
plateforme au service de la recherche et
des chercheurs et combien d'enseignants
chercheurs justement et d'élèves au sein
de lever ce qu il ya environ 500
étudiants et puis il ya une quarantaine
d'enseignants chercheurs alors vous vous
évoquez justement votre thème de
recherche la couche d'ozone comment en
êtes vous venu à vous intéresser à cette
cette perturbation à cette problématique
en fait j'ai toujours été intéressé par
le thème de l'environnement et quand
j'ai cherché un sujet de recherche on
m'a proposé un sujet sur la mesure de
l'ozone qui à l'époque était un gaz qui
est intéressant on savait qu'il y avait
enfin c'était dans les années 80 on
savait que c'était un gaz
atmosphére qui était sujet à des
problèmes en liaison avec la pollution
et les émissions de gaz potentiellement
destructeurs d'ozone mais il y a eu très
rapidement la découverte du trou d'ozone
dans les années 80 qui ont alerté
vraiment les la population mondiale sur
le problème de l'ozone car en fait
l'ozone atmosphérique c'est un gaz vital
pour la vie sur terre puisque c'est lui
qui filtrent le rayonnement ultraviolet
et donc s'il n'y avait pas d'eau zones
il n'y aurait pas de vie à la surface la
vie serait resté dans les océans et on a
senti mon truc même qu'aujourd'hui on en
parle beaucoup moins diserts moment oui
monsieur là on s'est beaucoup intéressé
aujourd'hui cette banda louis en fait
disons qu'on
on a un peu résolu le problème aussi
quelque part puisque à la suite de la
découverte du trou d'ozone on a très
rapidement fait des expériences et on a
pu trouver les coupables en fait qu'ils
sont des gaz chloré émis par les
activités humaines et le protocole de
montréal a été signé en 1987 donc très
rapidement il a été mise en oeuvre en
1989 et donc après on a suivi en fait
l'évolution de la couche d'ozone et on
s'est rendu compte en fait comme on
avait permis d'expliquer en fait les
problèmes de destruction d'ozone au
dessus de l'antarctique
du coup c'est vrai que c'est un
protocole qui à succès environnemental
important c'est considérer un peu comme
la succès story
de l'environnement parce que c'est un
protocole global qui permet de protéger
l'environnement l'échelle mondiale et
qui est appliquée et qui a permis de
stabiliser la destruction de la couche
d'ozone alors le évidemment on n'en
parle plus maintenant beaucoup moins
puisque la couche d'ozone s'étant
stabilisé on pense que c'est un sujet
qui est résolu sauf qu'il faut quand
même continuer à surveiller l'ozone
parce que les gascons a émis pendant
toutes ces années depuis les années 30
ce sont des gaz qui ont une durée de vie
très longue dans l'atmosphère et qu'il
faut évacuer et donc il faut suivre
l'évacuation de sept de ces gaz et voir
si l'ozone revient bien à la normale
comme c'est prévu par les différents
modèles atmosphériques ce sera en 2050
2060 voilà donc ça va prendre beaucoup
de temps faites mais donc il faut suivre
et voir si tout se passe bien comme
prévu alors nous venons d'évoquer la
problématique de la couche d'ozone qui
est lié aussi au réchauffement
climatique
mais avant d'aborder cela nous allons
écouter le climatologue jean jouzel qui
étaient venus pour une conférence à
l'eau vs q le 29 novembre dernier
des propos recueillis par catherine joue
l'atout et patrick jacques de dixmude
bonsoir jean jouzel bon soit 4 vous êtes
le présent du giec le groupement
d'études sur le climat et il faut le
rappeler vous êtes co lauréat du prix
nobel de la paix c'était en 2007 et puis
vous travaillez toujours au sein du
laboratoire des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement au sein du de l'ové ce
qu on se trouve là ce soir parce que
vous êtes venu animer une conférence
avec une thématique je trouve très très
large le réchauffement climatique où en
est on
on essaie vaste tout d'abord je tiens à
préciser que je suis vice président du
groupe scientifique du giec c'est vrai
que je suis impliqué dans le jeu depuis
une vingtaine d'années maintenant et
c'est une année importante puisque nous
sommes nous avons en quelques mois
publié le cinquième rapport du giec qui
effectivement sert de référence nous
sert de bison de base commune toute la
communauté scientifique
et la publication ses soeurs 2013 2014
c'est très important mais je continue
aussi avoir des qualités de recherche un
peu moins un peu moins un peu mois qu'il
ne faudrait peut-être cette cinquième
édition d'hier a un petit peu ce que je
veux dire annonce par exemple à une
augmentation des températures de 4
degrés d'ici cinq ans le temps restera
oui malheureusement c mais c'était déjà
dans le 4e rapport du giec à savoir que
c'était déjà dans le premier rapport du
giec si on émet
des gaz à effet de serre sans y prendre
aucunement attention et bien d en 90
nous disions que
après 2050 dans la deuxième partie du
21e siècle climat se réchauffe ray le 4°
de 3 4 degrés finalement il est allé les
rapports du siècle suivant était dans la
continuité on est toujours un peu la
même chose on se respecte mais on
précise oui je crois que d'ailleurs
c'est très bien je crois que c'est un
hommage la communauté scientifique les
projections qui avait été fait il ya 20
ans reste tout à fait valable évidemment
les a précisé leur caractère régional
m'a beaucoup appris en une vingtaine
d'années mais et c'est pour ça pour
répondre à votre question je crois
pouvoir dire que le cinquième rapport du
giec sera dans la continuité par exemple
et donc les modélisateurs français nous
avons deux deux modèles en france celui
de l'institut pierre-simon laplace dont
fait partie le laboratoire des sciences
du climat et de l'environnement et celui
de météo france les résultats étaient
publiés et on voit effectivement des
réchauffements important ça confirme ces
chiffres si rien n'est fait pour limiter
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre on
va parler de ce qui se fait aujourd'hui
on parle du protocole de kyoto parce
qu'ils se hissent achève la 1re phase
s'achève au 31 décembre 2012 évidemment
si on dit aux gens comme ça 4 degrés
d'augmentation de température finalement
c'est pas grand chose c'est plutôt même
sympathique maintenant il ya des vraies
conséquences noria il est vrai
conséquence il ya des vraies
conséquences on est souvent une image
fait moi même mon domaine ce sont plus
les climats du passé à paraître à partir
des glaces polaires et si on regarde la
dernière période glaciaire c'était il ya
vingt mille ans le niveau de la mer
était de 120 mètres plus bas
qu'actuellement et tout cela parce qu'il
y avait une énorme quantité de glace qui
était sur toute l'amérique du nord
disons l'europe du nord la scandinavie
donc c'était un climat très très
différent du nôtre mais en moyenne
globale la température n'était que de 5
à 6 degrés plus froides qu'actuellement
au 4° c
les deux tiers d'un changement entre
périodes glaciaires et interglaciaires
mais là la nature mis des milliers
d'années ils sont à effectuer cette
transition plus de 5000 ans là nous
sommes en train de faire cela en moins
de cent ans une centaine d'années c'est
vraiment ça la différence la capacité
d'adaptation elles existent mais les
limites et
on a de bonnes raisons de penser que si
le climat excède disons 2 degrés c'est
un peu une barre symbolique et bien la
capacité d'adaptation devra vraiment
commencera à disparaître dont donc jean
jouzel évoqué le réchauffement
climatique c'est une problématique qui
est directement liée avec celle de la
couche d'ozone pourquoi en fait les deux
sujets sont liés mais sont un peu
différent parce que la perturbation de
la couche d'ozone est liée à l'émission
de certains gaz qui sont les
chlorofluorocarbures qui ne sont pas les
hydrocarbures qui
induisent le changement climatique donc
ces deux problématiques un peu séparés
mais elles sont liées dans la mesure où
l'ozone est aussi un gaz radiatif qui a
un effet sur le climat donc une
perturbation d'ozone va avoir un effet
sur climat et de même la perturbation du
climat va avoir un effet sur l'ozone
donc les deux sujets étant liés ils sont
étudiés aussi
ensemble et justement le la
problématique du retour à l équilibre de
l'ozone dépend beaucoup du changement
climatique alors le changement
climatique justement vous préoccupe-t-il
c'est la question que nous sommes allez
vous poser dans les rues de 50 ans
aujourd'hui oui parce que nous on fait
attention maintenant à nos consommations
énergétique et on a mis sur notre toit
des panneaux solaires ça m'inquiète
quand même oui pour ceux pour les jeunes
pour les enfants pour tout le monde pour
ce qui arrive ça m'inquiète un peu oui
avec tous les phénomènes climatiques
exceptionnels qui peuvent se produire
sur certaines communes
c'est vrai que c'est un peu inquiétant
un petit peu parce que je vois que qu'on
ait besoin de voyager dernièrement il ya
des pluies partout il pleut partout sur
singapour la thaïlande et je pense que
ça vienne saiper que les la banquise
dégel
ou au contraire qu'il fasse très très
froid on sait pas exactement ce que
l'avenir nous réserve sur ce plan mon
avis si on fait rien pour envoyer ça il
y aura de plus en plus de phénomènes
tels les tempêtes sur une commune des
ravages comme ce qui s'est passé avec la
tempête xynthia et cetera
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il ya des
décisions politiques qui vont dans le
bon sens qui sont prises encore
aujourd'hui pour améliorer cette
situation lutter contre ce réchauffement
climatique mais les décisions sont très
timides c'est ce qu'on a pu voir le
résultat de deux doigts en fait bon il
ya quand même une volonté de certains
états pour réduire leurs émissions de
gaz à effet de serre notamment l'union
européenne qui s'engage avec des mesures
contraignantes mais il ya d'autres états
qui disent oui on va prendre des mesures
pour réduire nos émissions mais sans
s'engager dans un processus contraignant
donc c'est un peu ça le problème
actuellement mais je pense qu'il ya
quand même une volonté à l'échelle
locale dans certaines villes il ya quand
même à discussion ce drame ceux des
clubs c'est cela mon avis c'est pas
suffisant comment peut-on agir au
quotidien chacun de son côté s'il n'ya
pas réellement de volonté politique ah
bah il faut qu'on prenne conscience de
ce qu'on que tous nos actes en fait sont
générateurs des missions donc en prend
sa voiture on va émettre de du co2 quand
on prend l'avion on va émettre du co2
etc
donc il faut que toutes ces actions
puissent être enfin qu'on puisse réduire
en fait notre propre empreinte carbone
et donc je pense qu'une prise de
conscience de qui se fait de plus en
plus mais il faut que les gens soient
aidés aussi qu'ils puissent savoir
qu'est-ce qu'ils émettent lorsqu'ils
prennent leur voiture ou quelle est la
différence pourquoi ils doivent plutôt
prendre les transports en commun plutôt
que la voiture pour l'instant les c'est
encore à s'éparpiller il n'y a pas un
discours vraiment fédérateur sur le
sujet il ya passé d'éducation notamment
de sensibilisation chez les jeunes
aujourd'hui encore ça pourrait
s'améliorer les chances oui ça fait
partie de vos projets de nouvelle
directrice de lever ce cul oui enfin
disons que nous on agit plutôt sur la
partie ancienne union recherche
observations donc c'est plus sur
l'aspect recherche c'est pas tellement
sur l'éducation grand public même si la
vulgarisation a fait quand même partie
de nos missions donc effectivement on va
essayer de sensibiliser au maximum la
population locale ou nationale
merci à vous d'être venu nous présenter
les travaux que vous menez actuellement
à l'eau vs qu à saint quentin en
yvelines avec l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines puisque lovey
ce qu est une des composantes merci
également à valérie d'être venu sur le
plateau où l'on trouve la semaine
prochaine même heure pour une prochaine
chronique en environnement reste dans
l'environnement avec et dans un instant
l'association ville verte qui propose
dès mercredi club nature plus de détails
à suivre juste après ce reportage
réalisé à elancourt sur réduisons nos
déchets à une opération pour
sensibiliser les jeunes d'un centre de
loisirs donc le gros moteur virbac est
ce qu'on peut mettre dedans une peau de
banane ou d'orange ou alors des pelures
d'oignon oh
une question qui mérite réflexion
finalement permet toutes les études sur
ce petit quizz s'inscrit dans le cadre
de la semaine européenne de la réduction
des déchets auquel ce centre de loisirs
d'elancourt a souhaité participer tout
au long de l'année on a déjà on a un
potager on a protégé on fait du compost
à la nature l on a aussi des des animaux
à l'intérieur au sein même deux centres
de loisirs les animaux en question les
voici flocons est là footy en intérieur
et roger qui gambadent dans la cour on
change ça les tiers des fois et on est
dans le compost les activités du centre
de loisirs sont particulièrement axé sur
l'environnement et le développement
durable
question de sensibilité des animateurs
qui transmettent cet intérêt aux enfants
ici ces derniers font leurs propres
confitures et s'occupe du potager ce
jour là l'activité rennes c'est le
compost le convoi exceptionnel dirige la
brouette jusqu'à son but final aux
invités la litière d'eurogem des relais
dans le composteur pour quoi faire pour
mettre fin pour que ça fasse de l'ombre
et quand c'est ont pu l on puisse les
mettre dans la dans les plantes reste
plus qu'à attendre six à douze mois la
durée moyenne du compost